[Aplausos]
[Música]
llegué a la educación por casualidad
porque yo realmente quería ser
comunicador social realmente amaba esa
carrera sin embargo cambió mi
perspectiva hasta que en una oportunidad
mi mamá me dio un consejo que me pareció
muy importante en ese momento me dijo
hijo estudie educación porque un docente
es útil aquí y en la china
no importa si te toca dar clases hasta
debajo de un árbol no importa si te
encuentras en el pueblo más pueblo los
docentes siempre serán fundamentales
porque siempre habrá la necesidad de
educar a los niños y por ende tú siempre
tendrás trabajo seguro hazme caso hijo
tú tienes esa vocación tienes ese don y
bueno que abro paréntesis porque tu mamá
te pone todos los dones habidos y por
haber yo realmente sentía que no tenía
ninguna vocación para ese momento
pero lo que comprendí que cuando ella me
daba ese consejo nos encontramos en una
venezuela en la cual los comunicadores
sociales estaban siendo oprimidos por
todo este tema de la libertad de
expresión
así que me tocó poner en una balanza y
preguntarme allison será que estudies
comunicación social o de repente como
que intentas con educación
lo pensé de manera estratégica y terminé
estudiando educación pero para serle
sincero yo entré a la universidad con la
intención de decir la gente mira muchas
gracias por todo pero yo no quiero estar
en una hora de clase déjalo así no no no
pero resulta que cuando tuve la
oportunidad de hacer las prácticas
profesionales de trabajar en un aula con
los niños que por cierto fue una de las
mejores experiencias de mi vida la
vocación que estaba dormida despertó
porque es que definitivamente uno nunca
se rellena se deja de llenar de cosas
bonitas y positivas baratas en el
ambiente educativo
pues continúe contra todo pronóstico con
mi carrera y de verdad me fue buenísimo
me di cuenta que tenía la vocación mira
la educación es para mí yo puedo enseñar
a cualquiera me fue muy bien pero se
empezaron a presentar ciertas
situaciones en el camino que me hicieron
cambiar de parecer
típico cuando estás en una reunión
social y la gente se está presentando la
gente se está conociendo y alguien
pregunta mira qué te dedicas tú y por
allá saltado uno mira ingeniero
industrial y tú a qué te dedicas mira
soy doctor cirujano y de repente y a qué
te dedicas cuáles son bueno yo soy
maestro y la gente pone cara como dice
maestro
mira yo envidio tu paciencia
definitivamente yo no
tú estás consciente que va a pasar 30
años de tu vida dando clases
te van a dar varices mira yo tuve una
maestra que le dio mor roig des
y hasta se te puede caer el pelo y el
pelo gracias a dios no se me callo
porque no tengo pero tengo que admitir
que lo de las hemorroides casi casi pero
no vamos a hablar de esos detalles
también me decían en mi entorno que los
docentes siempre ganábamos mal que
nuestra carrera uno era lucrativa
y que tampoco teníamos muchas
oportunidades laborables con mucho campo
en el cual nosotros poder ejercer
y eso me molestaba siempre me preguntaba
porque si estaba consciente que
alrededor de la educación hay ciertas
circunstancias pero amaba mucho la
carrera y me molestaba la percepción de
la gente el porqué en la carrera es poco
lucrativa del por qué no te da
oportunidades laborales pero me tocó
avanzar en mi carrera con esas molestias
internas hasta que en una oportunidad
logré comprar una revista que me gustaba
mucho que hablaba de temas empresariales
la revista se titula titulaba en ese
momento su mejor artículo las 100
mejores empresas del país y sus 100
mejores gerentes
pueden creer que comprar la revista y
y
y ninguno de esos 100 mejores gerentes
era licenciado en educación
nadie era maestro de escuela porque
porque los docentes no podemos ejercer
en otros espacios distintos al aula de
clase y motivado por eso decidí que me
tenía que ir del colegio e irme una
empresa y no porque me gustara el
horario de oficina o porque no me gusta
la educación más bien yo necesitaba y
ahora la pedagogía a otro nivel
totalmente distinto
no lo logré pero bueno tuve que hacer
ciertas cosas para poder avanzar a nivel
profesional y logré estudiar
comunicación organizacional me saque esa
espinita estudio de comunicación
comunicaciones comunicación estudié
comunicación organizacional
y logré pertenecer a una de las empresas
multinacionales más importantes en venta
directa en mi país
un docente en el área comercial ventas
marketing haciendo lo mismo que hacía en
el aula de clase
enseñando capacitando planificando
elaborando recursos didácticos
nosotros los docentes tenemos un campo
de acción muy amplio no importa donde
nosotros nos encontremos
a partir de ese momento estaba muy feliz
por ese logro para mí era un gran éxito
realmente hasta que una oportunidad
estaba dando una charla a mujeres
emprendedoras ellas eran parte de la
fuerza de ventas de esta empresa al
finalizar la charla un grupo de ella se
me acercó y me dijo somos maestras como
tú logras de hacer lo mismo en otro
espacio totalmente distinto y recuerdo
que el ex les aconseje que nunca debían
permitir que las encasillar
y que debían salir del aula y no por
desmerecer este espacio porque considero
que el aula de clases es el mejor lugar
para que germine el proceso de enseñanza
y aprendizaje en todo su esplendor pero
considero que como docentes tenemos
mucho más rango de acción tenemos muchos
espacios en los cuales podemos lograr
grandes cambios a través de la educación
por ejemplo en uganda tras conflictos
armados la gente de los docentes se las
arreglaron para que eso fuese un aula de
clase
y aquí volvieron las palabras de mi mamá
hijo estudio educación porque un docente
es útil aquí y en la china no importa si
te toca dar clases debajo de un árbol
siempre habrá la necesidad de educar
porque los docentes son fundamentales
evidentemente ese no era mi objetivo
lamentablemente todo iba bien pero
venezuela estaba pasando por unas
circunstancias que obligaron a muchos
profesionales venezolanos a migrar y uno
de ellos soy yo
fue en ese momento cuando realmente
inició mi verdadero proyecto de vida un
proyecto que tan solo peso 23 kilos casi
nada y fue el salto de fe más grande que
dado en mi vida tan grande tan alto como
el mismo salto amén
la cascada de agua más alta del mundo
representación icónica de mi país así de
alto este salto de fe
23 kilos peso la única maleta con la que
la aerolínea me permitió viajar
en una maleta de 23 kilos tuve que meter
todo lo que yo podía llevar conmigo para
poder dejar mi país y utilizar los años
que me quedaban de juventud para poder
sembrar en otras tierras simplemente
como un método de sobrevivencia
en una maleta de 23 kilos que tuve que
meter todo lo que en 28 años de vida
había construido
todos mis logros todo esto fue como
quien se divorcia estando enamorado a la
fuerza sin anestesia emigrar en las
condiciones en las que a mí me tocó
hacerlo y hay muchos venezolanos en
condiciones mucho más extremas fue una
experiencia que volver a nacer como para
ponerlos en contexto recuerdo que me
bajó del avión en guayaquil guayaquil es
una ciudad espectacular pero tiene un
calor que imagínense yo basándome el
avión y lo primero que me recibe es ese
calor que yo sentí que me iba a morir y
aparte internalizar que estoy pisando
una tierra completamente distinta sin
una cédula sin documentos legales sin un
título registrado yo no existía
era yo y mi maleta de 23 kilos más nada
claro me empecé a sabotear típico no
mira a link son de verdad que ahora sí
que nos sacaste dejó un rojo era
definitivamente metiste la pata no
disculpa usted metió el cuerpo entero o
sea usted se hundió con todo y maleta de
23 kilos chau se no fue ahora si a eso
se la lora se se acabó lo que
se daba me disculpan de verdad me
dispensa
es que
definitivamente esto de emigrar no es
para ti tu el bohemio el del cambio la
educación más allá del aula no migra y
ya no tienes nada
y me tocó continuar porque mi familia
dependía de mí y ese allison del futuro
también ese allixon que confía
básicamente en su historia de éxito
sólo que para ello tenía que haber
dejado todo lo que había logrado todos
sus logros sus tics
a sus seres queridos y un sinfín de
memorias
pero bueno agarra mi maleta y me fui con
todo el optimismo porque se ve que esto
siempre te habla de frente al espejo tú
sí puedes tú te quieres mucho tú eres
inteligente tú lo puedes lograr y me
llené de todo es optimismo y es alegría
y continuo hacia delante mira lissón yo
no sé a quién te vas a encomendarse a
dios a la rosa mística pero tú tienes
que seguir hacia adelante
definitivamente y de verdad me fue con
esa alegría ya no solo voy a negar esa
vibra positiva porque yo puedo soy
allison marte yo estudiado y me lo
merezco y ese trabajo a estar para mí y
terminé limpiando alcantarillas
y trampas de grasa
cisternas
tuberías cuando usted lava sus platos
toda esa sociedad que se da por la
tubería bueno más atrás algo yo
limpiando definitivamente no mi cara lo
dice todo
[Música]
y me di cuenta que realmente no estaba
tan preparado para vivir grandes cambios
cambios de 360 grados como yo pensé que
lo estaban
ay me di cuenta cuando toque fondo
cuando realmente viví en la en la
posibilidad de que ya no tenía nada que
cosas que no nos enseñan en la escuela
hay cosas que un maestro no nos enseña y
que lamentablemente yo no enseñe
y nuestra educación sigue regida por un
sistema educativo cuyas bases de
enseñanza se basan en la repetición
monótona de conocimientos para que
aprendamos de manera mecánica conceptos
cifras que realmente poco o nada aportan
verdaderamente a la verdadera educación
del ser humano
cuando tú estás en tu zona de confort y
te toca saltar al vacío
sin saber a qué te enfrentas te toca
vivir un proceso muy complejo
de desaprender y de re educarte y eso
implica que tú tengas que romper ciertos
esquemas que tú tienes tan arraigados en
tu médula espinal que en tu día a día
como no lo necesitas romper no lo hace
porque lo tienes todo sólo hasta que
saltas al vacío y te das cuenta que no
tiene ninguna herramienta
nos cuesta que toque fondo que me di
cuenta que hubiese gustado tener aún una
materia donde me hubiese enseñado a cómo
sobrellevar el cambio cómo sobrellevar
la cruda realidad la soledad la
xenofobia
quien te enseña a ti a vivir oa convivir
con la xenofobia a tu alrededor
nadie yo no lo aprendí en la escuela no
lo aprendí en la universidad y me tocó
aprenderlo aquí a la fuerza a los golpes
la educación no solo debe servir para
enseñar a trabajar debe servir para
enseñar a vivir debemos educar para la
vida la educación tiene que ser vista de
otra óptica una donde el educando no
sólo aprenda a resolver problemas
matemáticos sino que es se para resolver
problemas del día a día que no solo
respeten las reglas gramaticales y
ortográficas sino que hagan un buen uso
del lenguaje y la comunicación donde se
demuestra inclusión donde demuestra
respeto donde demuestra empatía por el
otro
así para cuando alguna persona y la
experiencias como la que yo viví puede
enfrentarlas y no hablo de emigrar
porque esa es una de las tantas opciones
y escenarios retadores que se pueden
presentar aquí a través de este proyecto
de 23 kilos es que me di cuenta que
tenía que levantarme con más fuerza y
llevar la educación a otro nivel
y eso lo que yo hago actualmente no sólo
capacitar en habilidades técnicas sino
en habilidades plantas para que la gente
tenga herramientas y poder defenderse
ante cualquier situación extremas que se
le presentan mi intención acá no es
demostrar a las 196 claves de cómo
lograr tus objetivos no para nada y de
la felicidad
pero quiero que sepan y que estén
conscientes que hay algo que me parece
que es un hecho ya que tus logros tus
objetivos son cosas que tienes que tener
muy claras en tu mente y en tu corazón y
cumplirla contra todo pronóstico así
llueva truene o relampagueé
y verdadero valor el día de hoy acá no
no se basa en presentarme como el
coordinador de la escuela de ventas de
una de las empresas más importantes del
país filial de una de las marcas más
reconocidas del planeta y verdadero
valor radica en poder inspirar a otros a
través de la historia de resiliencia que
lleva mi nombre
este proyecto de 23 kilos este salto de
fe me permitió a mí ser testimonio de
algo centrarse en otros
y demostrarle al mundo que lo que haces
no no condiciona quién eres solo muestra
que te dedicas demostrarle al mundo que
tu entorno no condiciona tu futuro si tú
no lo permites
y que cualquier persona es capaz de
lograr lo que se propongan muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]